verläuft nicht
zahlreiche polizisten vor
rette mich retten
so leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde dragon escape medium und
berufsmusiker a hetz places und wir
legen direkt los war ein bisschen knapp
weil ich mal wieder habe es schon carla
34 aufnahme oder so probiert und ich
habe immer den start verpasst weil es
keine ahnung ich zog eigentlich nur es
gehe da bin ich nicht gewohnt so schnell
los geht wo der weg direkt im weg
glück gehabt und ich hasse dass wir so
viele halter herläuft
der blues ist abgehakt und wir haben es
geschafft nein nein nein der mann das
gleiche alter warum warum warum
oh nein alter was heißt sogar du meinst
du gewinnst du dir und ich hasse was
alters kaum welchen sprung machen ich
glaube wenn die rückwände dann kommt wir
machen jetzt eine runde dran dann möchte
einfach lieb drauf das hat sonst immer
geklappt dieser sprung immer immer älter
so ein scheiß
aber wer bist du verkalkt wäre den
meisten auf diese weise leute auf dem
hals erwerben dann werdet einmal stirbt
einfach sein würde hätte warum machen
die nächste helmut dedy um
ich sag ja wählen gewinnt alles zwingt
sich wenn er sagt dass er sogar weiter
ist ohne scheiß
dieser sprung nicht hast denn so besser
krieg ich hab' ich glaub ich über die
panik der hölle auf dieser leute ist
aber direkt herunter gefallen
oh gott nein nein was youtube usb alter
bist du mich verlassen
nein aber das war toll klappt ich hab ja
irgendwie einen ultra behebt nicht
gefolgt gott nein nicht veranstalter
da kommt alter schwede oh mein gott ist
aber ein bisschen länger genannt deshalb
fatal wenn dragon das camp lake ist
verkackt behindert nein was nein es kann
nicht sein das kann doch wer ist ein
sport alter ich hab' ich habe eine
selben stelle wie du vorher lieb
eingesetzt und ich habe einfach verkackt
voll ärgerlich auf einer anderen website
diese kann es ja gibt es noch andere mal
ich kenne diese zweite lara und papa
müssen wir machen
ja leute also wie gesagt ihr müsst
entschuldigen ich habe wirklich dreckig
geht man nicht so oft gezeigt ich will
nicht so fünf mal wieso man kannst mich
mal an einer hand abzählen
die mal die ich links der deutsche
starspieler bund deswegen habe ich noch
nicht so krass wetter ein bisschen üben
damit ich demnächst einfach ein bisschen
mehr abgehen kann ich wollte zum
aufladen mf5 modus was vorne drauf ich
bin tot
was läuft nicht
egal also wurde ich habe zuvor werde
mich natürlich
nein nein nein
eine runde gewonnen
5 modus gewonnen du kleiner alter junge
ich hab' ich habe vor diesem sprung so
panik alter
ich hab' ich hab für den sprung so panik
und mein gott meine runde das ist die
letzte aufnahme
ich glaub das alter egal leute wie
gesagt heute sondern entertainment runde
weil ich irgendwie energiegeladen aber
nicht ich weiß mich aus sagt aber ich
bin ja warum ist müde hat was von clanmo
wisst ihr was januar ist schreib mal die
kommentare nicht ich glaube ja kleinere
hatte heute ein kleines rohr also ich
meine wer dauer kleinen rohr aber
diese trinkwasser ich hab in 5 modus
zocken junge uralter ich hoffe dass ich
kann das nicht mit jetpack dinge ich
lebe nach
ich bin noch in leiferde geradezu mein
leben
was jetzt gerade hier da unter dieser
pyramide lama war und so handlich
gekommen
da kommen jetzt raus seid ihr beide
dauern jetzt bin ich bei diesem 1
ja wann fick dich einfach er wird nicht
er hat nicht vor kann ich komme ich hier
raus kommt hier hoch mitglied ist ja
okay leute dann würde ich sagen wir
haben rhein an dieser stelle war jetzt
drei oder vier und ich hab gar nicht
mitgezählt wie gesagt ich werde ein
bisschen üben ist ein bisschen besser
werde und ansonsten schreibt in die
kommentare was hier von halte das geld
wirklich gefallen hat gibt einen daumen
nach oben
und ja dann sag ich hoffe dass ich die
beiden anderen pass einer beschreibung
gepackt habe den ferien und in diesem
sinne ich trinke über kalkuhl macht's
gut leute davos und st